Hi, Data2100 students. We have
reviewed data quality. We took a
look at a mini small data set.
We've talked about how much data is
generated and consumed in the
world. But now let's get into Excel,
which is home and a BI tool for
much of data analysis that occurs.
Personally, professionally,
in organizations, Excel
is used all of the time and
in every single industry.
I would say 99% of
companies use some sort
of version of spreadsheets,
which Excel is.
So as much as Excel may be familiar
to you or unfamiliar to you,
I'm going to start with the
absolute base knowledge of Excel,
and we're going to give you a
quick crash course on Excel. So
I want you just to have enough
skills in Excel that you feel
confident in understanding rows
and columns, what data looks like,
and that you can do well on an
upcoming homework assignment.
Throughout the rest of the course,
we will bring in Excel here and
there to kind of get into our data
analysis portion of the class.
So Excel will be thread throughout
the class. So I don't want
you to feel like this is your first
and your only exposure to Excel.
We will definitely continue
to work in Excel. And it is a
fantastic business intelligence
tool that, again, is used by people
personally, professionally, it is
used all of the time. We'll also
review data quality as well. So
let's go ahead and jump into it.
So our objectives for
today are to understand the
significance of Excel, be able
to navigate Excel workbooks,
understand the significance
of the five data quality
characteristics, and develop
some core competencies in Excel.
So why is Excel important.
It's used in nearly every job.
Professionals use it to
find patterns and trends and
raw data. It supports business
analysts and decisions.
As we will learn, it is not
a long-term data storage
solution. Rather, it is
fantastic for doing, you know,
small reports, doing, analyzing
patterns and trends and raw
data. It is fantastic for so
many uses with data and is
used all the time. Now I will
say there are some organizations
that do treat Excel as a
home for a lot of their data.
However, we are going to do best
practices which are databases
and using those as long-term
storage for data, but Excel
is used, I cannot emphasize this
enough, in nearly every job.
All right,
so let's talk about what
does Excel look like. So
I'm going to go ahead and
launch an Excel workbook.
So you can see here, here
is an Excel workbook.
Hopefully you may have had
exposure to Excel, you may not
have. Either way that's just
fine. This Excel workbook
is going to have multiple
sheets here at the bottom that
we can create new sheets of
data. So we can right click,
you know, rename, move or copy,
what have you. So we have the
different sheets that we can have
within one Excel workbook. we can
also identify that there are cells
here that make up the workbook
so we can see here that we have
our rows and our columns worth
of cells and each of these rows
is going to represent some unit
of interest or some data instance
that we have so if we think
about maybe we're looking at, you
know, say we have a student ID,
first name, and last name.
So maybe student ID is A000,
whatever it may be, and their
first name is Beth Smith,
right? So now we have entered
in one record of data here
into our Excel workbook. So
Excel is extremely powerful.
Even though I've worked a lot
in Excel, I still feel like
I know a superficial amount.
It is extremely powerful.
So we're going to get you introduced
to it. So you can see here there's
a bunch of different things that we
can do up here regarding retrieving
data, creating formulas, viewing
it in certain ways, creating
different charts, graphs, you name
it. There's so much we can do here.
But this is in general an excel
workbook it has multiple sheets and
then we have rows and columns worth
of data we can come over here and
you can name the workbook and go file
save ads and name it and again you
may have had some exposure to excel
and if so that is fantastic um
the structure of a spreadsheet so
excel is home to spreadsheets right
you may have also used things
like google sheets those are also
spreadsheets. So the small boxes in
a spreadsheet are called cells. The
cells can be uniquely identified by
the column and row number. For example,
find the cell that is in column F
row four. Okay, so if we look at
this column F row four, this is cell
F four. You can see here in this
little tiny box in the upper left
hand, that is cell F four. So that's
how we uniquely identify different
cells in an Excel spreadsheet.
Now in that same cell that we
just located, we can go ahead and
write the name, or write hi, right,
in that Excel spreadsheet. So in
F4, we have written hi. So you go
ahead, hopefully you've already
launched Excel with me. If you
haven't, please do so. We're just
going to kind of play around with
Excel on this video to kind of get
you oriented, and then we're going
to also still talk about data
quality and how that relates to
Excel. So we have high here in F4. So
the value then of F4, what's
contained within that is high. Okay.
All right. Awesome.
let's look more at the structure
of a spreadsheet we have
records and rows which are a line
in a data set so if i am looking
here at this excel spreadsheet
we can see here that what
is highlighted there that is a
record we also call that a row
so it is that horizontal line
in a data set. That is a record
and also called a row of data.
We also have fields of data.
They can also be called columns,
attributes, variables. There's lots
of different names. We will refer
to them as columns and fields.
So a column or a field of data
runs vertically. So in this case,
this is all about the different,
this is all about, I believe
this is different customers
here, and this we are looking at
specifically that gender column.
So just keep that in mind. Rows
run horizontal, and then our columns
run vertical. A value is that
then that value is a data point,
right? So here, age 46, you can
see highlighted, that is a data point
or a value in my Excel spreadsheet.
Perfect. So why is data quality
important, right? Because bad
data leads to bad decisions, right?
Garbage in equals garbage out.
So we put garbage data into to
an analysis, we will get garbage
out, right? It's garbage data in,
not great decisions out of that
data. So just keep that in mind.
And why does it matter with Excel?
It matters with Excel
because Excel is such a
main point of where a lot
of data starts, right?
So data at one point or another is
more than likely going to find itself
in an Excel spreadsheet. and even
though we are going to be moving
on to databases an excel spreadsheet
highly mimics a database table
so we can kind of show you these excel
spreadsheets and we'll we'll fill
them with data and that will help
you as we get into the database
portion of this class okay so there's
five data quality characteristics
accuracy completeness consistency
time appropriateness and uniqueness.
We've already talked about those
five data quality characteristics.
to work with Excel a little bit
more here in a second. But let's
take a look at some data quality
pop quiz here. We've talked
about it. Now, this is a screenshot
of an Excel spreadsheet full
of data. So let's take a look.
So we can see here the first
name, household income, children's
state, and age as my columns.
And then I have all of these different
rows that are of different customers.
When I initially look at this Excel
spreadsheet, again, full of data,
I'm going to first, my I initially goes
to HHI, which stands
for Household Income.
So HHI, I can notice here that we
have some completeness issues going
on. I'm also noticing a very
large number down here on number
nine. I'm also noticing on five
there's quite a large number as well.
We may want to double
check the accuracy of
those numbers, but, you
know, good for them.
Looking here at children, we
can see also in the children
category that we have this
negative 20 appearing,
which that is something's going on there.
Also within my state column,
we can notice that we have a
completeness issue. And we also
have spelt New Jersey incorrectly.
The other thing that we should
notice here with this is
that at times there is a, well,
there is a consistency issue
going on here. I have CA and
then I have spelt out Ohio.
So sometimes in the data set, we are
just using the acronym or the two,
I should say the two, two letter
abbreviation for each state. And
other times we're spelling out the
whole state. so we need to think about
let's keep that consistent
throughout this whole entire data set
because if i had an nj here that would
appear different in a lot of data
analyses than new jersey right
because nj is not equal to new jersey
even though we think that the data
is not appearing that way so we would
need to keep this all consistent
and put nj down here and of course
also fix this Seattle issue, which
Seattle of course is a city and not
a state. So we're noticing, I hope
you're noticing, okay, I'm looking
at some data. I'm seeing there's some
data quality issues going on here.
And if I was to first calculate
household income off of this data
and I had this value and say that it
is incorrect, then all of a sudden
I'm going to report that our average
household income is extremely high
compared to maybe it's actually
not, right? So garbage in, garbage
out. We need to verify that what
data we do have, whether it's in an
Excel spreadsheet, in a database,
that it does have data quality, okay?
All right, so let's jump back into Excel.
And we are going to talk, we
already talked a little bit about
identifying cells, right? Remember
how we identify sales? We identify
sales by the column letters. So C5
is going to be right here, and we
can identify that in the upper left
-hand corner. So I'm going to give
you kind of a mini crash course
here on Excel basics. If you need
additional insight and help with
Excel, there's so many resources out
there. Reach out to me. I'm happy
to provide additional resources,
But I think that with this lecture,
with our in-class assignment videos,
you are going to be just fine with
Excel for this class. And again,
we'll weave it in and out of
the class as we move through it.
So we're going to end
that video right here, and
Okay, let's jump into our hands
-on portion of this video. So for
this section, we're going to be
working with the student scores,
Excel file data set. This data
set shows the exam scores of three
comprehensive exams taken by
each student in the fields of
math, writing, and reading. Alright,
so let's take a look at this.
So if I look at that student
scores data set, which you are
able to download up above this
video, you can see here that
we have the different, the
student ID, their college year,
their writing score, their math
score and their reading score.
of Excel is functions and formulas.
A lot of these functions
are calculations you
would perform in math
class, except Excel does it
in a super simple,
reproducible process for you.
Before that we learn about
formulas and functions, we must
learn about ranges of Excel.
So there are multiple range
There are multiple range examples
throughout the next few slides.
I encourage you to follow along,
especially with your student scores
data set. So let's go ahead and
do this. So I want you to select
the range of A1 to B6. Okay, so
let's do that. So I'm going to flip
back over here to A1 and B6. So
A1 is here in my upper right-hand
corner. I can see A1 and I want to
select down to B6 okay so I have
A1 to B6 selected so that is a
range that we are selecting in our
Excel spreadsheet so that's what
it should look like right so I
just want you to get away I want
you to be aware of what different
ranges look like in Excel this
will be important so if this seems
really simple just hold on we'll
get to the we'll get a little bit
more advanced. Now I want you to
select the range of C5 through C10.
So you can see here C5 through C10.
So at that point I have selected
all of that data. I could at this
point if I want to, I could copy this
and I could say control C or right
click and say copy and come over here
and say select and paste and it
would paste that data there for me.
So you can see here we're just
highlighting different ranges in Excel.
Last one here, please select
the range of B5 through E5. So
if you want to go ahead and
do that, you can absolutely do
that. This is what it's going
to look like, is you are going
to select B5 through E5, which
is going to be a portion of
that row. So if we do this,
we're going to grab B5 all the
way through E5. Now we've
selected that range worth of data.
Finally, we're going to select
all rows in six and seven. So
if we do that, we can go here,
highlight rows six and seven,
and I've highlighted both of
those rows. So now we can copy,
we can paste, we can insert, we
can up all sorts of different
things, but selecting ranges
is really important in Excel.
All right, perfect. So this
is what this looks like.
We select row six and
then we dragged our cursor
down to row seven. So I hope
that this has been helpful
just in selecting the
different ranges in Excel.
One of the most powerful aspects of
Excel is the ability to reference
other cells and ranges. So to learn
how to do this in my student scores
Excel spreadsheet, we are going to
add the scores for, we're going to
look at cell C30 and cell C31 and
add those two scores together in cell
C34. So down here in cell C34, I'm
going to zoom in here a bit more.
I'm just pressing control and zooming
in with my mouse if that helps,
if that is helpful for you. So if I
want to say, you know what, I want
to add the score of, let's see, the
writing score for this junior and
this sophomore, I could say equal
to cell C30, so we see that's how
we uniquely identify that cell,
and then cell C31. We do those two
things, and we see that we get 167 is
their score, their combined writing
score. So I did that through the
use of this here. I'm starting, if
you will, a formula, so I say equal
to, and then we add C30 plus C31.
Okay, perfect. And then we are,
after we do those two things,
So I say equal to C30 plus
C31, I just hit enter, and that
is where my calculation comes
from. So just keep that in
mind. That is how I can use cell
references to, in this case,
add these two scores together,
and I am referencing those cell
values. Now, if, for example,
if C31's score changed to 75,
then instead of 70,
that score change is 75,
then it is automatically going
to change this cell down here's
value. So because I've referenced
that cell's value, if it changes,
it's going to change that
calculation, which is powerful and it
also is something to keep in mind
when you're working in Excel.
Okay, perfect.
Now once we have done that,
a lot of times you want to
copy formulas across different
ranges. So for example, what
if we wanted to have this
same thing happen in cell D34?
So if I wanted to add
together cells D30 and D31,
instead of having to do this thing
again of equal to and type it
all out here, I can actually have
this same thing, the same formula
apply to the column in D. So if
I just drag over, so if I use my
handy little autofill tool, I can
grab this cell and drag it over.
And then what I see is 110
appears. If I double click on that,
I can say, oh, well now it's
saying equal to D30 plus D31.
So it transferred that formula
over to this next cell, and as
such, because it is based on cell
references and it's all relative,
then I can say, oh, yeah, I'm
going to add D30 plus D31. I can
do the same thing again. If I want
to say, hey, let's do the same
thing for this column in E, I
want to add those two students'
scores together, I drag it over,
and I can see 181 is going to be
E30 plus E31 added together.
Okay. So just keep that in
mind. That's really helpful
in Excel is that you can have,
if you write something one
time and you want it to apply
to different columns, we can
absolutely make that happen.
And there's a lot of
nuanced ways of doing that.
All right. Perfect.
So we talked about the
spreadsheets. So there
are two different types
of cell references.
The reference we just did in the
previous few slides was relative.
The cells moved based
on the position of the
cell performing the
calculation. So if I was to,
the different types of references
are relative and absolute. So
if I was to do a similar thing
here, but instead, so if I was to do
this, right, 167, it becomes 110.
If I was to use absolute cell
reference here, what this does
is I would put a dollar sign in
front of each of these. You can
also use, I believe, F4 as your, if
I was to put a dollar sign and make these
absolute cell references here,
then when I drag over this formula
into this next column, it's
actually going to give me the same
value because it is sticking with,
it was absolute to those cell
references. So before my previous
example, it was relative to it,
meaning if I move that formula over
into column D, then it was going
to add these two together. It
was relative to where it was in
relation to that formula. But if
I do an absolute cell reference,
it's always going to point back
to these two cells of C30 and C31.
So we will talk more about this
as we on through the semester.
But I just wanted to point that
out to you, that if you make a
cell reference absolute, then
if you change that formula, or
if you move that formula, try
to apply that formula in other
ways, it's still going to refer
back to those same cells. And
there's different times we would
use an absolute cell reference
and a relative cell reference.
We can also do things like a semi
-absolute, and we'll talk more
about these as we move forward.
Alright, perfect. So we
just did that example.
So now since we're using cell references,
we are referencing those cells.
now that we know a little bit more
about cell references and ranges,
let's talk more about formulas and
functions. So we just did a formula
when we said equal to this cell plus
this cell. So formulas start with an
equal sign. This equal sign then
allows for calculations or conditional
statements to be used. There are
multiple operators that can be used.
We can find their operators
and the descriptions here on
this slide. So an operator is
something like the addition
sign or the minus sign, the
asterisk does multiplication, the
forward slash does division,
and the caret does exponent.
So these are all things that
you should be familiar with.
There are different types of
operators we could use, but
these are really the standard
ones that we are going to use in
this class. So if we want to
add certain things together,
we can use our plus sign,
right? If we want to subtract
a cell value from another
cell, we can do a minus sign.
So that's a formula, which we've
already talked about. We can also do
things like functions in Excel. So
if I wanted to figure out what is
the average of all of the writing
scores here in my Excel spreadsheet.
So if I wanted to find
the average, I could say
if I wanted to find the average
of all of the writing scores, and
I'm dealing here with the writing
score here in column C, I could
say, all right, let's find that
average. So I'm going to use an
equal sign, and then I'm going to
use a built-in function in Excel.
So Excel comes with so many different
functions, but this is a very,
very common one. See, if I just
type in A, here is all of these
different functions. If I type in B,
here's all these different functions.
So there's so many. So I'm going
to type in average and I just
want to find the average of all of
these different values in the column
C. So I'm going to drag, I'm going
to start with cell C2 because
that's where my first writing score
exists. So I am capturing this
whole range. Do you see why we now
talked about ranges, right? So I'm
going to say, find me the average
of the data in this range. So I've
identified, here's a range of
data. I want you to perform this
function, meaning calculate the
average of all the data in this range.
Then I hit enter, and there's my
average. So there's my average writing
score. Now, you guessed it. We
learned about this. But what if I
wanted to find the average of the
math score and the reading score?
Well, now I just grab my little handy
autofill tool, drag it over, and
it's going to apply the same
calculation to the column D and to the
column E. So just keep that in mind,
that now I have, do you see how
powerful Excel can be? How quick
it can make things happen? So now I
have my three different averages
calculated using a function in Excel.
Super exciting.
All right.
So I have all sorts of different
functions. I can do things like the
min, the max, the sum, the count,
the average, and the median. So
let's just do another one really
quickly. We can find the median here.
And I can say equal to median.
I'm going to type out the median.
And then I come up here and I
grab cell C2 again through C31. So
I'm going to say perform this
function or calculate the median
on this range of data. So it's
cell C2 through C31. I hit enter.
And now I can see the median
for the writing score was 81
.5, the next score was 78, and
then 82. So I can start to
do some analysis here, right?
I can say, hey, on average,
our students are doing better
on the reading score, okay?
Yet, though, our median for
reading and writing score is very
close to one another. So I can
start to analyze this data.
We can also do things like finding
the max of the writing score,
the math score, and the reading
score. So you can absolutely keep
doing max, min, count. There's all
sorts of different functions here.
But normally when we just try
and do it on our own and we're
using our calculator, it takes a
long time. But Excel is so fast
in doing these quick data analyses
for us. All right, perfect.
We can also do things
in formatting the cells.
I can do things in formatting
cells. So just quickly here, I can
say, hey, I wanna bold. I can
highlight this whole range right here.
Say I wanna bold each of these
different column headings
here. I also want to change
them so they can be red.
Maybe you also would like to make
the student ID a little bit larger,
the college year a little bit
smaller, whatever. You can do all
sorts of different things. You can
change the direction of the font. You
can do conditional formatting.
There is so much here within Excel.
This is just a very
simple introduction to
ranges in Excel, to
formulas and to functions.
We will do more in Excel and
use it in a really applied way.
We can also do things like
we can sort and filter.
So if I want to say here, I want
to sort by, I'm going to come
down here and I'm going to delete
34 and 35, I'm going to delete
all that data. So I just highlighted
it and pressed my delete key.
So say here I want to sort by
writing score. So I can come up
here in my home, I'm going to
come over to sort and filter and
I'm going going to say sort
largest to smallest. I'm going to
expand the selection, meaning
it's going to sort all of the
records based upon the writing
score. So I'm going to say sort.
And now I can see here that
the highest writing score is
298s, 297s and 96 and on down.
So now I can, this is in a
different order, so now all of
these rows here are sorted by
the person with the highest
writing score is at the top and
the lowest score is at the
bottom of the Excel spreadsheet.
So it's sorted all of my rows into
a new order now having the two,
the highest writing score to the
lowest writing score as my order.
I can also do things and I can
say, you know what, I only want
to, instead of doing largest to
smallest, I could do from sort
smallest to largest again expand
the selection and I do that and now
I have my two lowest scores
appearing I can also come up here to
my sort and filter and say filter
and I now I want to say you know
I only want to see scores um in
the 50s and so I can just unselect
everything and then just grab
50, 54, 55, and 57, and press OK.
And now I'm only seeing
those students that
scored in the 50s on their writing score.
So this filter is very
helpful to filter through
data, to sort data,
those types of things.
All right, awesome.
So that's all I have for you today
in this Excel crash course. We are
going to do an in-class assignment
with Excel. Then we're going to get
into databases and writing SQL
queries, but it's important for you to
have a grasp of Excel as we'll be
using it sprinkled throughout the rest
of the course, and it's a good way
to start off the course and getting
used to working with data. All
right. Thanks, everybody. Take care.